il avait disparu de nos écrans de vos
écrans depuis de nombreuses années les
plus jeunes d'entre vous ne savent même
pas ce que c'est je veux parler du carré
blanc
il se situait quelque part par là il ya
quelques années sa droite de votre écran
et ils vous signaler que le programme en
cours allait présenter quelques audaces
quelques excès dans le domaine du sexe
ou de la violence par exemple
or un sondage publié cette semaine
démontre que les français souhaitent en
majorité le retour de ce carré blanc en
fait c'est le débat sur la violence à la
télévision qui a relancé à l'initiative
d'ailleurs de notre chaîne antenne 2
mais qu'est-ce qui est le plus violent
une fonction une fiction ou un reportage
qui montre la réalité des évènements et
c'est l'image de violence qui sont
diffusées régulièrement influence-t-elle
notre comportement les chercheurs des
psychologues les professionnels de la
télévision réfléchi et c'est à partir de
là que bientôt le csa devra prendre des
décisions
un dossier délicat stéphane magnier
qu'elle soit diffusée dans les oeuvres
de fiction ou dans les actualités aux
heures de grande écoute ou pas 61 % des
téléspectateurs s'affirme choqué par la
violence mais lorsqu'il s'agit pour de
faire la part du réel et de l'imaginaire
il exprime bien plus qu'une simple
nuance 93% pense surtout aux programmes
alors qu'une majorité se déclare non
choquée lorsqu'elle fait partie de
l'information et les jeunes eux-mêmes
selon le sondage de la vie ils sont en
contradiction apparente avec leurs aînés
et deux tiers d'entre eux ne sont pas
choqués par la violence à la télévision
génération de l'agressivité ou
perception différente du problème
c'est ce que serge me serais à essayer
de savoir ce matin à l'arrêt clé
maintenant ça me fait ni chaud ni froid
on va on va tellement c'est la violence
je zappe et oui j'aime pas les violences
on en parle de trop faire montre
beaucoup de choses déjà lancé une sorte
de bagarre ça vous aide pas non mais
quand ça bon quand on commence à tuer et
c'est comme ça avant de suite tout le
monde la suite oui on a beaucoup et
quand le méchant c'est tuer ça vous
dérange pas non pas celle où les siennes
dérange ou les guillotines méchant à
partir de quel moment la violence doit
plus être regardable bon on est
conscient on ride with bagarre et quels
sont ceux qui dans les parents les
empêche de regarder les films d'horreur
parmi vous et vous les regardez quand
même je présume la première tentation
parental c'est donc l'interdiction ou à
défaut le bon vieux carré blanc puisque
61% sont partisans de son retour sous
une forme ou une autre et pourtant
pour les spécialistes de la question la
violence peut avoir des aspects positifs
je ne pense pas qu'il faille censuré
parce qu'il faut montrer les unes et les
autres et je crois ce qui me paraît très
important c'est que les parents puissent
pendant et après ces émissions discuter
avec leurs enfants communiquer avec eux
et tout au fond là je dirais pas la
consommation mais la perception de
l'image télévisée de la séquence
télévisée soit quelque chose qui ne soit
pas une espèce de produits finis mais
que ça puisse donner l'objet à des
discussions et des échanges est allé
communication salue mille et familiale
constaté tu de la statistique la
violence chez les jeunes a diminué ces
dernières années en même temps que le
sentiment de sa présence à l'antenne
augmentait la télé premier baby sitter
de france suscite rethel le débat
familiale ce ne serait pas le plus petit
et paradoxes de la faire